morning captain Peralta I'd like to
introduce you to someone
his name is Simon and I hate him
hello Simon this is Balthazar he's an
evil demon who spits fire my throat go
either huh
anyway I've been looking over these
photographs of the restaurant and I've
identified several other known mob types
No
what is it did you see something no I
just got very cold very fast and now my
entire body is somehow on fire oh these
moms are jerks oh I also noticed this
van is parked out front in several other
photographs I never noticed that the
restaurant must have been under
surveillance I bet it was the feds
they're right I'll reach out to my
contact at the bureau I'll see if I can
get us some footage good idea also I
know you're not supposed to but I kind
of want to put my month bad idea I'm
going in here we go hurry up already
trust me I know what I'm doing between
the foster homes and the orphanage I had
lice 22 times holy wow that's a big one
all right pencils down everyone we've
got lice oh God Meredith lice did you
not sign a pledge to shower watch lice
oh my god lock the doors run full
quarantine twice relax it's just lice
maybe possibly just
lice Pam of all of the vermin in God's
great green kingdom lice are the ones I
detest the most my first day of school I
had lice and no one would play with me
for 15 years they called me freak and
four eyes and sci-fi nerd and girl
puncher all because I had lice when I
was seven hmm so we've developed a
revenue-sharing a formula that will
hopefully appeal to most business owners
lately go home you're sick I'm not sick
it's just allergies come on guys just
let me in there
I say you look tired and you're all
sweaty you look tired you're all
sweating all the time what's your Excuse
you want to go there Jerry Oh fine I'm
coming gotta barricade the door now
either go home or go back into
quarantine I'm not going home
get out of here Leslie go home hit the
bricks oh no no no she's German up all
my stuff Oh yuck Leslie did we take too
much cold medicine not by a long shot
Balthazar's a thirsty [ __ ] I'll drink
to that
[Music]
wait look hmm
Margo oh sorry you can't talk anymore
Madison Garibaldi he's eating snakes
yeah it's spaghetti oh so it's spaghetti
I'm just saying if that's spaghetti
it looks like snakes what are you
wearing it's a hazmat suit that sends
for hazardous materials men's suit
wearing if you rent more than four times
a year it just makes sense to buy is
there anyone else here that is lice-free
excellent you have your own house Matt
suits no renters okay I'm gonna need you
to gather your belongings retreat to the
warehouse conduct your business there
until the infected have been deloused
let's get going I'm gonna stay here and
fight if you don't hear from me by lunch
call me I might want lunch hey what did
you do to that perp I heard he's
claiming police brutality
he's an idiot I didn't touch him I just
coughed on him a little just let me help
you
I'll get your perp to talk I can be very
persuasive I'll just negotiate it my
baby girls down from a pony to a hamster
little fools I don't need your help
because I am not sick Gina where is the
cold medicine I hate to point out the
obvious oh but why do you need the meds
if you're
sick huh to fight off the cold symptoms
that my healthy body is exhibiting I'm
going back in there once this crap
drives my head up Damon
okay if he has one except I help we got
to go behind her back
we definitely should go behind her back
that's the opposite side of where the
germs are coming from guys I think we
should always up on Meredith this has
got to be hard for her oh no no no I
have not yet begun to shame that's it
I'm getting my stuff I believe it for
the day No Steel II if you leave now
they're trying to save you from yourself
oh right I'll stay that's pencil poking
at my rolls wait a minute why did you
just go in the kitchen do we have eyes
in the kitchen their eyes everywhere man
ow ow
eggie eggie ow look he slipped the
chef's piece of paper I bet it's the
address of his hideout the chef knows
where the hideout is his name is richie
Lunardi we talk to him we find Garibaldi
we have to go right now oh right uh yes
my disgusting deformity um here
majestic hey what's up girl better it's
not worse we're on our way right now to
talk to a lead that knows we're carob
all these hideout is you're quarantined
you can't go outside spewing mums like a
couple of month out ins not like this we
can't
[Music]
stop you can't leave it all good luck
trying to stop us you'll never catch us
a B is Usain Bolt
is this the piece of paper you're
looking for you throw me a dress no it's
a recipe for baked ziti
it was taped to your wall the entire
time you're delirious and you're sick
and you definitely didn't solve the case
you need to go back inside well I can't
I like stopped working the moms have
reached my testicles all right Gina we
have to act soon that cold medicine Diaz
chugged it was the non-drowsy kind she's
all over the place I got a new lead
that's my firm about is a drug dealer on
State Street hello
no there's no Michael here you're the
wrong number goodbye I'm Michael that's
a dumb name but it's yours and you
should be proud of it because you are
the greatest detective I've ever known
no doy yes no doy she's so hopped up on
that stuff her brain's gonna blow I'm
gonna interrogate the perp you keep the
as occupied I don't want to get near her
germs face permission to lock her in a
distant room no just distract her yes
that is what I will do Reza I gotta tell
you something is a secret okay but I
like stuff I do
I guess now that we got chipping a cap
as our headliner I can get rid of my
awesome wish list yeah those are long
shots Bob Dylan's friends I just thought
maybe they could get Bob Dylan to come
land ho god I love them everybody does
there's no way they're getting back
together their lead singer split ten
years ago he titled their last album
will never reunite Leslie Knope back in
your text icky I'm sorry but chip
maquettes manager called he has to drop
out no okay we need all hands on deck oh
there are no hands to be on deck because
everybody's at the winery okay Andy you
and I need to handle this we need to be
operating at maximum capacity skull
Vampires follicle gypsies hair lawyers
one thing is clear kill or be killed
it's more of a nuisance really it's not
that big a deal
so did your hats in your coat too baby
wash what do we do about our heads I'm
not gonna lie Wow excuse me she's right
it works
I would imagine yes it helps to
suffocate the little buddies and it's
really healthy alternative to the
chemicals found in most lice shampoos I
can appreciate that I also only local
organic produce boom take a picture
it'll last longer we don't want it to
last longer it's horrible bald people in
eat meat sick yeah yeah everybody pile
on Meredith but I'm the only one with
the balls to show them lice who's boss
okay nobody panic if everybody just
follows my instructions then nobody else
needs to end up bald not that it looks
bad Meredith it looks it looks awesome
you look like a baby who'd suddenly aged
50 years a cute baby
but something suck the life force out of
it I'm so sorry
we need mayonnaise we need it now oh
I'll go okay a big deal please no I'm
Meredith I think it just something
special mom at the store candy or or one
of those stylish turbans thanks pin him
I'll take a pack of nicorette gum and a
pack of Kools okay
let's talk pubes people everything okay
with Diaz yeah she fell asleep five
minutes after I locked her in and she
hasn't moved in the past ten hours she
talks in her sleep
you